[Music]
Abby Lee Miller is in the business of
winning dance competitions not losing
them but that's never stopped the ALDC
from experiencing some devastating
losses fans were stunned when the girls
on Dance Moms delivered stunning
performances only to win second place
we've compiled the ten biggest
competition losses to ever rock of the
cast of Dance Moms watch until the end
to find out which duet performed by
Maddie Ziegler and Chloe Lucchese ACK
should have won first place but didn't
Oh Josie WA and Abby Lee Miller haven't
always gotten along
Abby has scolded her for her lack of
manners in the past and her constant
need to talk back to adults so when Abby
gave Jojo the challenging straighten up
solo in season 5 episode 16 fans were
curious to see if she had the discipline
to knock it out of the park
Abby tasks Jojo with developing her
technique and she surprised everyone by
delivering a flawless performance during
the Dance Kids USA Invitational hopes
were high seeing as it was the girls
last day in LA and dojos contemporary
solo straighten up was nothing short of
miraculous
yet somehow Jojo didn't even place for
once Abby and jessalyn agreed on
something the judges had made a big
mistake Jojo was so scared of what Abby
would say to her she started to cry
after hearing the results
luckily dodo had also performed the
group dance platinum alongside Kalani
Kendall Maddie and Nia and the girls
brought in first place overall
so Abby cut Jojo some slack yes
if there's one dance style McKenzie
Ziegler has down to an art it's
acrobatic jazz so when Mackenzie
performed the solo shoulda coulda woulda
in season two episode six
fans were stunned when she didn't place
McKenzie had big hopes for solo week but
they all came crashing down after the
award ceremony and quite frankly it was
hard to watch but McKenzie wasn't the
only dancer who failed to place the same
thing happened to Kendall after
performing the lyrical number sweet
little lies the little girls were
obviously upset and Maddie Ziegler
chimed in stating that the floors had
been very slippery the MA dance
competition in Texas had been held in a
school gymnasium instead of on a stage
which could have contributed to
Mackenzie and Kendall's performances
being less than perfect although a few
mistakes could be spotted in Mackenzie's
routine she definitely should have
placed in the competition sometimes your
ego hurts more the expression on Abby
Lee Miller's face when she watches her
students perform says it all if she
looks happy chances are her girls are
going to win but if she looks slightly
upset or worst of all angry it's a clear
indicator that her girls aren't going to
place this is it we have to win right
here right now unfortunately this was
the case and rotten to the core when
Kendall performed the jazz number mask
at the wild dance intensive competition
in Detroit it's easy to see that Kendall
had her choreography down perfectly
every move was falleth
still something about Kendall's
performance had a be shaking her head
from side to side turns out that it was
Kendall's facial expressions and not her
technique that landed her in hot waters
with her teacher
Kendall's facial expressions definitely
knocked some points off her routine
still viewers couldn't believe that
Kendall hadn't placed it all but soon
enough the real reason behind the
judge's ruling came to light Kendall who
was 9 years old at the time had competed
in the eight-and-under category which
had resulted in her being disqualified
the kid has never forgotten
you've taught her never say never one of
the most disappointing moments from
season seven happens in Battle of the
blondes in this episode bran lily and
Maisie are each given challenging solos
which they perform at the dream national
dance competition in San Diego Brynn has
given the contemporary solo botched and
she crushes it her performance was both
precise and emotional and she gave
Maddie a run for her money when it came
down to facial expressions on top of
that Brynn kicked off the solo with a
piece of fabric covering her face which
couldn't have been easy fans of the show
stated that Bryn's performance was one
of the best contemporary solos in the
entire series and yet for some strange
reason Brynn placed third friend's mom
Ashlee was quick to point a finger at
the judges calling them incompetent and
many other parents couldn't help but
agree with her it wasn't an easy loss
for Brynn those judges should probably
never work again that's how bad they
were in the episode titled 99 problems
but a mom ain't won the girl's head to
Niagara Falls New York to dance in the
sheer talent competition the things
don't exactly go as planned for Kalani
Hilliker who places second despite
giving one of the most beautiful and
passionate performances of the season
Kalani performed danced til I die a
specialty number that should have won
her first place but sadly didn't viewers
couldn't help but wonder if Chloe
Lucchese act would have won first place
for the ALDC if she had danced in
Kalani's place after all dance till I
die was originally going to be danced by
Chloe and not Kalani either way Abby Lee
Miller was happy with Kalani's
high-heeled performance
luckily for Kalani the competition
wasn't a total loss after all she had
also performed the musical theater
number freakshow alongside candy Maddie
Mackenzie and Nia which has scored the
number one spot in the preteen division
do you think Chloe would have won first
place if she had performed Kalani's
number tell us in the comments
to come all no it's her mother in the
season 2 episode no one likes a bully
Abby Lee Miller ruffled a few feathers
when she switched out Paige for Kendall
in the group nothing more annoying than
a man Paige's mom fought tooth and nail
to keep Paige in the dance but Abby
brushed her off and made her decision
final she's just doing it to hurt her
despite the last second change Chloe
Maddie and Kendall performed the musical
theater number at the Hollywood vibe
competition in Missouri but things
didn't exactly go as planned due to a
technical issue
Chloe's placement was off but instead of
sympathizing with her a be blamed Chloe
for botching the performance nothing
more annoying than a man didn't place
and Abby was livid but technical issues
aside it was clear that Maddie Chloe and
Kendall had nailed their performance
which left fans feeling confused
Kelly was quick to point out that
Chloe's placement wouldn't have been off
if Paige had remained in the group
number but she was alone in thinking
that Maddie Paige and Chloe has always
won first place everywhere there's no
denying that Maddie Ziegler is one of
the best dancers to ever appear on Dance
Moms but the same can be said about
Chloe Lucchese ACK who continuously lost
to Maddie but shouldn't have on numerous
occasions in the season 3 episode the
politics of dancing
Maddie and Chloe competed for the number
one spot in the Junior solo division the
girls of the ALDC attended the power
house dance Philadelphia Invitational
and delivered some truly beautiful
performances but no dance was more
beautiful than Chloe's lyrical solo am I
here to stay and yet somehow Chloe
placed second losing to Maddie Maddie
who performed the contemporary solo I'm
trying
when first place despite viewers feeling
like Chloe had outperformed her in more
ways than one it was sad to watch
Chloe's face drop when Maddie was
announced as the winner
Chloe fans had been certain that she had
finally bested Maddie but obviously the
judges thought otherwise i won
Maddi because of her technique on other
hand I wanted about the Chloe because
she did the best with what she's had
blame it on the new girl was one of the
most upsetting episodes of season four
especially for Kendall fans the girls
traveled to Toledo Ohio to compete in
the intensity dance competition and
Chloe Fallon Kendall Maddie and Nia
brought home the number one spot with
their contemporary group dance red with
envy
but the competition wasn't over for
Kendall who also had the lyrical solo
just rain to perform this was without a
doubt one of Kendall's most stunning
dances she managed to keep her legs
perfectly straight during her front
Ariel's which was most impressive fans
were certain that Kendall would be
crowned as the winner but surprisingly
the number one spot went to Gavin from
the candy apples Dance Center Cathy
Nesbit Stein was thrilled over the fact
that one of her dancers had beaten
Kendall and she threw it in Abby's face
but fans are still confused as to how
Gavin's contemporary dance better when
you're there managed to be Kendall's
when she clearly outperformed him your
size nor your mouth intimidate me things
quickly got heated in the season one
episode from ballerinas to showgirls all
eyes were on Chloe and the pressure was
on for once
Abby plays Chloe at the top of her
pyramid giving her a chance to prove
herself in this episode the girls head
to Las Vegas to compete in the
thunderstruck dance competition and Abby
gives Chloe the musical theater solo
Missy knew as a reward for her hard work
but despite giving a spectacular
performance Chloe doesn't end up placing
at all and well there's probably an
explanation for that
you see before the competition Abby
bully Chloe and treated her rather
poorly Chloe you wanted this shot your
mother oh this is your shot so much so
that Christi got into a heated argument
with Abby
instead of coaching Chloe and making her
feel good about herself Abby spent the
entire week comparing her to Maddie and
repeatedly telling her that she had to
win at all costs the pressure proved to
be too much for Chloe who despite giving
a great performance didn't
home any titles I'm done
Chloe bouquets yeah can Maddie Ziegler
were often petted against each other on
the set of Dance Moms and yet something
magical happened every single time they
shared a stage in the season 2 episode I
know what you did last competition
the girls head to Waterford Michigan to
compete in the energy dance competition
and Maddie and Chloe joined forces to
deliver the lyrical duet inside of me
but despite delivering a breathtaking
performance Chloe and Maddie were
awarded second place in the junior duet
division everyone at the ALDC was
stunned over the judge's ruling what's
worse is that lifetime never aired the
performance of the team that beat them
so fans were left wondering about the
team that bested one of Maddie and
Chloe's greatest duets of all time on
the one hand it was nice to see Maddie
and Chloe acting like friends instead of
rivals but on the other hand fans felt
like the girls were robbed at the number
one spot without much explanation and
that's a wrap
before you go tell us who your favorite
Dance Moms star is in the comments below
and be sure to tell us which one of
their dances should have won first place
but didn't the show must go on
thanks for watching for more fun videos
be sure to LIKE and subscribe we'll see
you next time on the things